das motto dieses parteitages
nachzudenken
das motto die mottos der bundes
parteitage zu bestimmen war übrigens
immer eine der schwierigsten
angelegenheiten meistens habe ich mich
erst auf den letzten drücker auf den
allerletzten drücker entschieden und
damit die mitarbeiterinnen mitarbeiter
des konrad adenauer hauses insbesondere
die die für die herstellung der
buchstaben und das anbringen des mottos
zuständig waren regelmäßig in
verzweiflung gestürzt um nicht zu sagen
in den wahnsinn getrieben
wahrscheinlich auch deshalb haben wir
heute die modernste rückwand aller
zeiten und alle buchstaben probleme sind
für immer gelöst
[Applaus]
ich kann ihnen allerdings gar nicht
genug für alle hilfe und nicht nur bei
dem parteitagsmotto sondern in gesagt
insgesamt für einen einsatz danken
vorneweg möchte ich euch fleißner und
eberhard zeigen was sie mit ihnen und
mit ihnen alle mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeiter des konrad adenauer hauses
zu leisten imstande sind
das habe ich in den über 20 jahren in
denen ich mit ihnen zuerst als
generalsekretärin und dann als
vorsitzende gearbeitet habe jeden tag
erlebt
muss das noch ein bis ich bin klein aber
nicht so klein und ich möchte unseren
bundesgeschäftsführer klaus schüler
nennen der mich mit einer kurzen
unterbrechung ebenfalls seit über 20
jahren begleitet er hatte
[Applaus]
er hat in den letzten acht regionale
letzten wochen acht regionalkonferenzen
mit vielen tausend teilnehmern
buchstäblich aus dem boden gestampft er
hat diesen parteitag vorbereitet er ist
eine institution in unserer cdu ich
danke ihm und allen mitstreiterinnen und
mitstreitern von ganzem ganzem herzen
[Applaus]
und ganz besonders möchte ich in dieser
stunde des abschieds auch allen meinen
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeitern im
büro der parteivorsitzenden im
konrad-adenauer-haus danken
ich werde den fleiß aller den einsatz
die kompetenz und das herzblut das das
ganze konrad adenauer sind die arbeit
für unsere cdu steckt niemals vergessen
danke
[Applaus]
und ein herzlicher dank auch allen
mitgliedern der präsidien und bundes
vorstände seit im jahr 2000 schlichtweg
allen weggefährten für unterstützung für
kritik für ideen für beistand für
verbundenheit danke
[Applaus]
liebe freundinnen und freunde mein
erstes parteitagsmotto nach der
spendenaffäre als neu gewählte
vorsitzende der cdu deutschlands in
essen im jahr 2000 lautete zur sache das
war für viele gewöhnungsbedürftig wo
steht hier deutschland nirgendwo steht
hier zukunft nirgendwo steht hier etwas
von gestalten von werten von sicherheit
nirgends nur zur sache
damit fing es an typisch merkel sache
knochentrocken
[Applaus]
das doch ist rütter exakt das aus worum
es in jener zeit ging als die cdu am
boden lag als sich unsere gegner schon
die hände reiben dass wir uns von der
spendenaffäre niemals erholen würden und
deshalb sage ich an dieser stelle auch
mit großem ernst
die zeiten heute sind fordernd ohne
jeden zweifel für unser land für die
volksparteien für cdu und csu mit der
afg als einer partei rechts von uns mit
einer polarisierung in der gesellschaft
doch mit ebenso großem ernst sage ich
eine schicksalsstunde der christlich
demokratischen union deutschlands die
haben wir vor 18 jahren erlebt das war
die bewältigung der spendenaffäre als
die cdu politisch moralisch und nicht zu
vergessen finanziell vor dem aus stand
als nicht wenige hier ein schicksal wie
das der italienischen demokratie
christiana vorhergesagt hatten
doch wir haben nicht klein beigegeben
wir haben uns nicht irre machen lassen
wir haben einen kühlen kopf bewahrt
wir haben uns unsere auf unsere eigenen
stärken besonnen wir haben unseren
eigenen stärken vertraut und wir haben
es allen gezeigt wir haben alle folgen
der spendenaffäre überwunden auch die
überaus harten finanziellen wir haben
zurück zur sache gefunden
[Applaus]
wir haben die nach der wahlniederlage
1998 begonnenen erneuerungsprozess
unserer partei wieder aufgenommen
fortgesetzt und intensiviert 18 jahre
später 72 landtags- bundestags- und
europawahl kämpfe später die
kommunalwahl kämpfer habe ich jetzt
nicht mitgezählt 72 wahlkämpfe später
also übrigens 72 mal an wahlabenden
hoffen banken leiden jubeln und gewinnen
verlieren heute nun das motto
zusammenführen und zusammenführen
mein letztes modell cdu-vorsitzende und
wieder typisch merkel
wo steht hier deutschland nirgends wo
steht ihr zukunft nirgends steht der
etwas von gestalten von werten von
sicherheit nirgends oder liebe
freundinnen und freunde flüchtete
vielleicht steht all das was ein
klassisches parteitagsmotto ausmacht
dass uns ja den weg in die zukunft
weisen soll zwar nicht in den buchstaben
an der wand aber dafür umso mehr in den
buchstaben in diesen vier worten
zusammenführen und zusammenführen
zusammenführen was sonst als unser land
als deutschland als europa als die
generationen die älteren und die
jüngeren als ost und west stärkere und
schwächere stadt und land einheimischen
migranten als uns alle als cdu und csu
in zeiten wie diesen
[Applaus]
und zusammenführen der sonst als wir
christlich demokratische union
deutschlands
wer sonst als wir mit unseren wurzeln
der konservativen der
christlich-sozialen der liberalen mit
unseren werten mit dem c in unserem
namen dem christlichen verständnis für
menschen mit unseren führungsanspruch
als der volkspartei der mitte in
deutschland
cdu und csu gemeinsam wohin uns nicht
innen den wollender streit führt das
haben cdu und csu in den letzten jahren
bitter erfahren
[Applaus]
wohin uns einigkeit führt auch das haben
cdu und csu erfahrung von bald 70 jahren
bundesrepublik deutschland haben cdu und
csu 50 jahre den bundeskanzler bzw die
bundeskanzlerin gestellt 50 jahre
die anderen 20
dass das so bleibt das aus 50 jahren
führender regierungsverantwortung auch
über diese legislaturperiode hinaus noch
mehr jahre werden können
dafür stellt dieser parteitag heute die
weichen
[Applaus]
und dass cdu und csu von 70 jahren
bundesrepublik deutschland 50 jahre
regierungsverantwortung wahrgenommen
haben das ist kein anlass zu stolz
sondern anlass zur demut
das sollte es jedenfalls sein wende
gelungen ist das weil wir immer auf
beides geachtet haben politik zu
gestalten auf der grundlage unserer
werte aber auch mit der bereitschaft
wahrzunehmen was um uns herum geschieht
weil wir verstanden haben dass wir nicht
alleine die weisheit gepachtet haben und
es sich lohnen kann die welt immer auch
mit den augen des anderen zu sehen weil
wir fast immer der versuchung
widerstanden auf die schnelle und
scheinbar einfache antwort zu setzen
statt sich um tatsächlich dauerhaft
tragfähige antworten zu bemühen
bei der freude daran hatten dass die
welt und das leben nicht schwarz-weiß
sind sondern voller schattierungen und
vielfältig bunt weil sie an die kunst
und die kraft des guten kompromisses
geglaubt haben bei dem die vorteile
natürlich die nachteile überwiegen
weil wir immer wussten dass konservativ
nicht von konserve kommt sondern davon
zu bewahren was uns stark macht und zu
verändern was uns hindert
[Applaus]
weil wir immer wussten dass es auf jeden
einzelnen von uns ankommt von der spitze
bis zum gerade eingetretenen neuen
mitglied weil wir wussten dass schon
eine einzige stimme den unterschied
machen kann ja dass ein einziger sitz
den alles entscheidenden unterschied
machen kann zwischen sieg und niederlage
so wie jetzt in hessen volker bouffier
seine arbeit und die seiner
schwarz-grünen landesregierung mit genau
einem sitz mehrheit fortsetzen kann
[Applaus]
das ist bei aller enttäuschung über die
verluste der cdu bei der landtagswahl
ein großer grund zur freude und zur
dankbarkeit und zugleich haben wir immer
gewusst dass die parteien die eine oder
einer alleine ist sondern immer alle
mitglieder zusammen
die ortsverbände kreisverbände
bezirksverbände landesverbände
vereinigungen bund land und kommunen
hand in hand liebe freunde es ist noch
nicht lange her dass wir erlebt haben
gemeinsam welche kraft welche die magie
namik wir auch dann entfalten können
wenn uns der wind ins gesicht bin ich
sage nur saarland über 40 prozent
ich sage nur
[Applaus]
ich sage nur schließlich holstein die
stadt kann zeigt ganz leicht zurück
erobert mit daniel günther
[Applaus]
und ich sage nur nordrhein westfalen rot
grün in die opposition nicht
[Applaus]
liebe freundinnen und freunde das alles
waren wir die cdu wir gemeinsam das
zeigt wir haben die kraft trend zu
brechen wahlen zu gewinnen wenn wir
zusammenstehen wenn wir geschlossen und
entschlossen gemeinsam kämpfen sowie im
jahre 2005 die sie über in den
landtagswahlen in schleswig holstein und
nordrhein westfalen
der alles entscheidende schlüssel zum
ende von rot grün waren zu waren im
frühjahr 2017 als ihr ganzer kraft ein
überaus kompliziertes um gegen ein
überaus kompliziertes umweltamt umfeld
an gekämpft haben die siege bei den
landtagswahlen im saarland in schleswig
holstein und nordrhein westfalen der
alles entscheidende schlüssel dafür im
bund rot-rot-grün verhindert zu haben
[Applaus]
liebe freundinnen und freunde als ich
mich auf diesen parteitag vorbereitet
habe habe ich mir selbst fünf fragen
gestellt
die erste dieser fünf fragen lautet was
hat sie und nicht als cdu vorsitzende
vor über 18 jahren eigentlich
zusammengeführt damals nach der uns so
sehr zu setzenden spendenaffäre war es
sicher vorsichtig gesprochen ein kleines
wagnis
vor allem aber in unerschütterlicher
glaube an die zukunft mit dem wir uns
aufeinander eingelassen haben in meiner
ersten bewerbungsrede um den
cdu-parteivorsitz in essen im jahre 2000
im jahre 2000 habe ich erzählt wie ich
1989 in die politik fand
und ich möchte aus dieser rede in essen
ein paar kurze sätze zitieren damals
1989 sind wir aufgebrochen
ich bin mit meinen kollegen los gezogen
mich zog es in den demokratischen
aufbruch der name war programm
das war für uns alle eine unglaubliche
zeit große neugier auf das neue einem
freund habe ich in seinem buch
geschrieben gehen soft was ist das für
eine aussicht gehens offene in die
freiheit in die neue zeit unsere zukunft
so habe ich zwei tausenden essen gesagt
hängt einzig und allein von unserer
eigenen stärke
die haben wir selbst in der hand wir
wollen die treibende kraft in
deutschland wir wollen sein wir wollen
wieder die nummer eins werden
rot grün kann sich warm anziehen denn
jetzt geht es wieder zur sache für
deutschland für die menschen
zitat ende
[Applaus]
liebe freundinnen und freunde ich glaube
wir können sagen einiges davon haben wir
umgesetzt und geschafft und darauf
können wir gemeinsam stolz sein und zwar
alle miteinander
zweitens was verdanken wir einander
unendlich viele stunden tage und nächte
gemeinsam nachdenken des verhandelns
entwerfens verwerfen ringens um die
besten antworten auf schwierigste fragen
in einer immer komplexer werdenden welt
nach bestem wissen und gewissen für
anträge für wahl- und regierungsprogramm
für ein neues grundsatzprogramm
so haben wir zum beispiel die regierung
schröder bei den hartz-reformen
unterstützt
denn sie waren mit dem prinzip des
förderns und forderns die richtige
antwort auf die damals fünf millionen
arbeitslose und dass wir heute knapp
über zwei haben darauf können wir
miteinander stolz sein
wir haben die richtigen reformen
unterstützen
ja meine klare antwort gegeben ob die
immer weiter steigende
staatsverschuldung die schwarze null war
und ist die richtige antwort für
generationengerechtigkeit und
zukunftsfähigkeit und wir können stolz
darauf sein dass das jetzt schon viele
jahre so ist wieder freunde
wir haben eine klare antwort gegeben auf
die veränderte internationale
sicherheitslage im übrigen nicht auf 22
minuten auf einem parteitag sondern nach
einem ganz langen diskussionsprozess
durch alle land landesverbände wir haben
die wehrpflicht ausgesetzt wir haben die
bundeswehr in eine neue form gebracht
wir haben noch viel zu tun sie zu einer
schlagkräftigen armee zu machen
aber der schritt war richtig liebe
freunde auch wenn er manchem schwer
gefallen ist
das klatschen das klatschen ist schmaler
als die mehrheit damals war als
entschieden wurde auf dem parteitag
wir haben wir in einer für mich als
sternstunde in erinnerung bleibenden
einigung von christlich demokratische
arbeitnehmerschaft und
mittelstandsvereinigung ein eigenes
modell für den mindestlohn entwickelt
und damit gezeigt dass wir über die
verschiedenen flügeln weg kooperations
und einigungsfähig sind eine große
stunde der cdu
wir haben klare antworten gegeben auf
die europäische staatsverschuldung
wir haben eine klare antwort gegeben auf
die wünsche der menschen familie und
beruf besser vereinbaren zu können durch
elterngeld durch kita-ausbau durch
baukindergeld durch vereinbarkeit von
beruf und familie
wir haben spannendste ethische debatten
miteinander geführt ich erinnere an die
großartige debatte zur
präimplantationsdiagnostik auf einem
unserer partei zahlen und liebe freunde
wir haben auch und die große
herausforderung bestanden 2050 in einer
humanitären notlage viele menschen bei
uns aufzunehmen und trotzdem dafür zu
sorgen dass gesteuert und geordnet wurde
ich erinnere nur an das eu türkei
abkommen
liebe freunde auf unsere partei hat sich
schritt für schritt weiterentwickelt wir
haben partei reformen angepackt die
beteiligungsmöglichkeiten für mitglieder
ausgebaut und unsere kommunikation der
digitalen welt angepasst
bei all dem haben wir uns gegenseitig
nicht geschont
wir haben uns gefordert wir haben uns
auch gegenseitig etwas zugemutet ich
euch aber ich erlaube mir zu sagen dass
es auch ganz ganz selten natürlich auch
mal umgekehrt waren
[Applaus]
und wie sollte es auch anders sein wir
sind ja eine familie und das alles haben
wir gemacht immer in der tiefen
überzeugung dass nur so fortschritt und
entwicklung entstehen können möglich war
das alles nur mit gegenseitigem
vertrauen dafür ganz besonders dafür
danke ich euch
[Applaus]
drittens was haben wir uns vorenthalten
sie haben mir gar nichts vorenthalten
habe intensiv darüber nachgedacht
mir ist nichts eingefallen ich habe
umgekehrt ihnen und euch so manchen
richtig deftigen scharfen angriff auf
den politischen gegner ob von links oder
rechts vorenthalten und stattdessen das
florett gewählt oder es vorgezogen zu
schweigen und gar nicht erst über das
stöckchen zu springen das nahm er hin
hielt ich weiß sehr wohl dass ich eure
nerven damit mehr auf die bürger
gestellt haben
[Applaus]
viertens warum trennen sich jetzt unsere
wege natürlich nicht die vor mir und der
christlich demokratischen union für
meine verbundenheit mit dieser partei
brauche ich keinen parteivorsitz und
bundeskanzlerin bin ich auch noch
[Applaus]
doch es ist mein verständnis als
bundeskanzlerin und als vorsitzender der
cdu deutschlands dass die demokratie von
der mehrheitlich getragene übereinkunft
lebt dass ihre staatsdiener alles in
ihrer macht stehende für den inneren
frieden und den zusammenhalt unseres
landes tun und dass sie sich immer
wieder prüfen was sie dafür auch ganz
persönlich tun können
das ergebnis seines nachdenkens kennen
sie
deshalb werden wir auf diesem
bundesparteitag in hamburg eine neue
führungsmannschaft fehlen mit ihr mit
verbunden mit dem prozess für ein neues
grundsatzprogramm kann sich die cdu auf
die zeit nach mir einstellen es ist mir
eine herzensangelegenheit in der letzten
legislaturperiode meines politischen
arbeitens einen beitrag zu leisten mit
dem neuer erfolg der cdu unter
gleichzeitiger wahrung staatspolitischer
verantwortung ermöglicht wird so können
wir die weichen für die zukunft stellen
[Applaus]
liebe freunde dass es eine zukunft die
größte herausforderung für uns
bereithält
ob das die polarisierung unserer
gesellschaft ist in der zu oft die
radikalsten und schriften töne gehör
finden ob dass sie allen alterung
unserer gesellschaft ist die unsere
sozialen sicherungssysteme vor ganz neue
herausforderungen stellt ob das der
technologische fortschritt ist der uns
viele chancen bietet von der medizin
über die mobilität bis zur energiewende
der war auch fragen an die menschenwürde
stellt beispielsweise in der
abhängigkeit von algorithmen oder
energien forschung
ob das die verschiebung der
wirtschaftlichen gewichte in der welt
ist bei der regionen aufholen und uns in
vielen bereichen schon überholt haben
ob das die zunehmende abkehr vom
multilateralismus ist der rückzug ins
nationale die reduktion internationaler
zusammenarbeit auf die prinzipien des
stil mailings oder der drohenden
handelskriege ob das krieg gewalt terror
hunger und perspektivlosigkeit sind die
weltweit so viele menschen wie noch nie
seit dem zweiten weltkrieg aus ihren
heimatländern fliehen lassen und uns
auch in europa für eine große
bewährungsprobe stellen ob das die
hybride kriegsführung oder led
stabilisierung ganzer gesellschaften
durch fake news ist ob das die zukunft
unserer europäischen union ist die
gemeinsame währung eine gemeinsame
europäische verteidigungs und
sicherheitspolitik oder der brh exit der
eine tiefe zäsur für europa bedeuten
wird ob das der klimawandel ist der
sollte er nicht eingedämmt werden können
dass angesichts unseres planeten
verändern wird oder der plastikmüll in
den meeren der die schöpfung an den rand
des kollapses bringt angesichts all
dieser und unzählige weitere
herausforderungen sind einmal mehr
gerade wir die christlich demokratische
union deutschlands gefordert zu zeigen
was in uns steckt
wir sind einmal mehr gefordert unter
beweis zu stellen dass wir in zeiten wie
diesen unsere art zu leben unsere
liberalen werte und unsere interessen
entschlossen verteidigen nach innen wie
nach außen
[Applaus]
als partei für die mit ihrem
christlichen menschenbild der einzelne
mensch mit seiner unantastbaren würde im
mittelpunkt steht als partei die sich
für den zusammenhalt unseres landes
einsetzt als partei die weiß dass das
erwirtschaften vor dem verteilen kommt
als partei die ein klares bekenntnis zu
europa zur transatlantischen
partnerschaft und zu einer
multilateralen ordnung abgibt und dieses
genau auch lebt unsere cdu ist heute
eine andere als im jahr 2000 und das ist
gut so denn die cdu
[Applaus]
denn die cdu des jahres 2018 ist die cdu
die den anspruch haben muss nicht in die
vergangenheit zu blicken sondern sich in
die kuh zukunft zu orientieren
mit neuen köpfen mit neuen antworten mit
neuen strukturen aber mit bleibenden
werten
und deshalb liebe freundinnen und
freunde zum abschluss fünfter
was wünschen wir einander
ich wünsche mir für uns gemeinsam dass
wir auch in den schwersten stunden seien
die aufgaben noch so komplex und die
anfechtung von außen auch noch so stark
nie vergessen was die
christdemokratische haltung ausmacht
[Applaus]
wir christdemokraten grenzen uns ab aber
niemals grenzen wir aus
[Applaus]
wir christdemokraten streiten und zwar
nicht zu knapp
aber niemals hetzen wir oder machen
andere menschen nieder
[Applaus]
wir christdemokraten machen keine
unterschiede bei der würde der menschen
wir spielen niemanden gegen den anderen
aus
[Applaus]
wir christdemokraten verlieren und uns
nicht in selbstbeschäftigung und
selbstbespiegelung der christdemokraten
dienen den menschen unseres landes
[Applaus]
die zukunft für uns alles abverlangen
wasserkraft haben unsere werte zu
behaupten und zu bewahren
die zukunft gut gestalten können wir nur
wenn wir uns nicht mit missmut mit miss
uns mit pessimismus sondern immer mit
fröhlichkeit im herzen an die arbeit
machen
so habe ich es immer immer für mich
gehalten in meinem leben in der ddr und
erst recht und umso mehr unter den
bedingungen der freiheit es ist diese
fröhlichkeit im herzen die ich meiner
partei auch für die zukunft wünsche
[Applaus]
dann werden wir christdemokraten auch in
zukunft erfolgreich zusammenführen und
zusammenführen
zum wohle unseres landes zum wohle der
menschen für deutschland und für europa
als ich liebe freundinnen und freunde
vorgestern in washington an der
trauerfeier für den verstorbenen
früheren amerikanischen präsidenten
george bush teilgenommen habe habe ich
noch einmal gespürt wenn ich ein
unfassbar großes glück es war das 1989
gerade dieser staatsmann präsident der
vereinigten staaten von amerika
[Applaus]
dass er in dieser entscheidenden
historischen stunde den mut und die
kraft aufbrachte
uns deutschen und vorneweg dem damaligen
bundeskanzler der bundesrepublik
deutschland helmut kohl zu vertrauen
dass er damit entscheidend den weg zur
deutschen einheit frei machte in
einigkeit und recht und freiheit für das
deutsche vaterland
ich habe gespürt was es bedeutet wenn an
der spitze eines mächtigen landes ein
mensch steht der politik als staatskunst
zum wohle aller versteht der sich dazu
in der stunde des größten triumphes des
westens des sieges der freiheit über die
tyrannei von mauer und stacheldraht
zurück nehmen konnte weil das dem alles
überragenden ziel dienen würde den
kalten krieg zu überwinden
wir deutschen müssen präsident george
bush auf immer dankbar sein und ebenso
der staatskunst und der weitsicht des
kanzlers der einheit und europäischen
ehrenbürgers helmut kohl
[Applaus]
ohne sie ohne ihre politik wären wir
heute nicht die vereinte cdu
deutschlands von 15 landesverbänden
baden württemberg berlin brandenburg
bremen hamburg hessen
mecklenburg-vorpommern niedersachsen
nordrhein-westfalen rheinland-pfalz
saarland sachsen sachsen-anhalt
schleswig-holstein thüringen über 18
jahre lang vom zehnten april 2000 in
essen ist im heutigen 7
dezember 2018 hier in meiner
geburtsstadt hamburg der stadt unseres
vereinigungsparteitag es 1990 durfte ich
vorsitzende dieser großen großartigen
stolzen einzigen volkspartei der mitte
in deutschland der christlich
demokratischen union deutschland sein
eine aufgabe die ich mit leidenschaft
und hingabe versucht habe auszufüllen
ich wurde nicht als kanzlerin geworden
und auch nicht als parteivorsitzende
wahrlich nicht ich habe mir immer
gewünscht und vorgenommen meine
staatspolitischen und parteipolitischen
ämter in würde zu tragen und sie eines
tages auch in würde zu verlassen
denn wir alle stehen in der zeit und
jetzt ist es an der zeit ein neues
kapitel aufzuschlagen heute in dieser
stunde in diesem moment bin ich von
einem einzigen alles überragenden gefühl
erfüllt von dem gefühl der dankbarkeit
es war mir eine große freude es war mir
eine ehre
herzlichen dank
[Applaus]
ja meine damen und herren drei minuten
geht er nun schon der anhaltende applaus
standing ovations schilder werden
hochgehalten danke schaffen und sie
hören es
[Applaus]
es kommt doch schon zu
ja
ansatzweise zu maultaschen situation im
positiven sinne
hier zeigt eine partei dankbarkeit
ihre chefin gegenüber 18 jahre 8 monate
solange also ist die zeit von angela
merkel als parteivorsitzende der cdu
deutschlands und damit ist sie eine der
prägenden gestalten dieser partei helmut
kohl 25 jahre konrad adenauer 16 jahre
das sind die drei großen partei spürbar
als hörerin dabei die partei zeigt sich
dankbar und angela merkel hat es in
ihrer rede auch an mehreren stellen
gesagt gezeigte demut die war dankbar
für die aufgabe die sie von der partei
das vertrauen was sie erhalten hatte
diese aufgabe zu erfüllen
aber sie sagte auch ein oder und sie
sagt auch einen ganz entscheidenden satz
unsere cdu von heute ist gemeint ist
eine andere als die cdu von 2000 und das
ist gut so
damit zeigt sie auch eindeutig dass sie
selbstbewusst ihre ergebnisse der
letzten 18 jahre weiter verteidigt
gerade auch vor dem hintergrund der weg
des jahres 2015 ihre entscheidung die
grenzen zu öffnen
die hat sie hat das c im namen der cdu
ganz klar definiert wie sie hat ganz
klar gesagt dass die menschenwürde
unantastbar ist und sie hat das
vielleicht auch schon mit einem
augenzwinkern
möglichen nachfolger oder ihrer
möglichen nachfolgerinnen damit auch ins
buch geschrieben das das werte sind die
unumstößlich sind daran muss
festgehalten werden
und die hatte ja auch davon gesprochen
mit fröhlichkeit im herzen die zukunft
gestalten das soll vielleicht auch ein
ja sagen sie mal einen einen appell an
die drei kandidaten seien geeint all
nach der wahl ein sieger wird es geben
oder eine siegerin aber trotzdem danach
weiter zu arbeiten und die ergebnisse
die verdienste die partei in den 18
jahren erreicht hat zu bewahren und
nicht aufs spiel zu setzen meine damen
und herren während ich hier rede wir
sind jetzt schon in der sechsten minute
des applauses erhältlich er hält an er
reist gar nicht ab von wie die stimmung
bei den delegierten ist das kann uns
jetzt hautnah anke partner sagen bitte
schön ja vielen dank heinz abel versteht
man sein eigenes wort nicht natürlich
bei mir so laut applaudiert dass wir
bleiben hier bei dem ort wo dieser
parteitag stattfindet nämlich bei den
delegierten aus hamburg von brot was
empfinden sie bei diesem moment